In 1298, a manuscript was published that took
Western Europe by storm.
Known today as the Travels of Marco Polo,
it detailed the Venetian’s adventures in
Asia - from India, to Japan, to Sri Lanka.
Impressive as those tales were, though, it
was the figure at the heart of Book Two who
really set Europe alight.
The wise, ancient emperor who ruled a China
so wealthy, so enlightened, that it seemed
like Heaven on Earth.
That great emperor’s name was Kublai Khan,
founder of the Yuan Dynasty and grandson of
Genghis Khan.
He would go down as one of the greatest rulers
in Asian history.
At the time of Marco Polo’s visit, Kublai
Khan sat at the head of an empire so big,
it defies comprehension.
A Mongol warrior trained from birth in the
art of war, he’d nonetheless grown into
an emperor who valued Buddhism, science, and
progress above conquest.
A towering figure in both the Western and
Chinese imagination, this is the story of
Kublai Khan: the Mongol warrior who became
a Chinese emperor.
The Great Khan
When you hear the name Kublai Khan, we’re
guessing you also hear the incredibly famous
opening of Samuel Taylor Coleridge’s poem:
“In Xanadu did Kubla Khan, a stately pleasure
dome decree.”
Aside from being two of the most-famous lines
in English, they also perfectly sum up the
Western vision of the emperor: a semi-mythical
aesthete living a life of unparalleled elegance.
Which means it can come as a shock to realize
Kublai Khan wasn’t born in a grand palace
and didn’t spend his life swanning around
in silk pajamas.
No, when Kublai first opened his eyes on September
23, 1215, the sight that greeted him wasn’t
the rarefied air of the Chinese imperial court…
…but the mud and din and savagery of the
Mongol Empire.
Just nine years earlier, Genghis Khan had
united the rowdy, drunk nomadic herders of
the Mongolian steppe into a rowdy, drunk army
that was nonetheless one of the most-effective
fighting units on Earth.
Although the empire’s early days had been
marked by forward-thinking policies like banning
the kidnapping of women, that progressivism
had quickly given way to conquest.
In 1209, Genghis Khan invaded the neighboring
Xi Xia Kingdom, beginning the process that
would lead to his descendants controlling
the largest contiguous empire in history.
By the time Kublai was born in 1215, Genghis
had flattened the Xi Xia, crushed the Jin
Dynasty, and captured Zhongdu - the city we’d
now call Beijing.
We mention this because Kublai wasn’t just
some random kid born to some random Mongol.
Kublai’s father was Tolui, the youngest
son of Genghis Khan.
Well, the youngest legitimate son.
Given that one in 200 men today are direct
descendants of Genghis Khan, we’re guessing
there were quite a few illegitimate younger
sons out there.
Now this didn’t mean Kublai grew up bouncing
on Genghis Khan’s knee as he conquered the
world.
In fact, Kublai barely saw his grandpa or
his father.
Instead, he was mostly raised by his mother,
the Christian princess Sorkhotani Beki.
This meant a somewhat unusual upbringing by
Mongol standards.
For one thing, Sorkhotani was a ferociously
intelligent woman, and taught Kublai and his
brother Möngke to read at a time when literacy
came a distant second to being able to bring
down an antelope.
For another, she also made sure to expose
her boys to Chinese culture and philosophy.
The impression this made on Kublai was so
great, it would eventually change the course
of Asian history.
Still, Kublai wasn’t a pampered little prince.
Before he was 10, he was a formidable horseman,
hunter, and fighter - all things the Mongols
needed if they were to keep on conquering.
And conquering was by now what the Mongols
were all about.
When Kublai was just five, the Central Asian
Khwarezm Empire made the fatal of insulting
Genghis Khan.
By the time Kublai was ten, Khwarezmia had
fallen, leaving the Mongols in charge of an
empire that stretched from the Sea of Japan
to the Caspian Sea - a distance similar to
that separating Memphis, Tennessee from Honolulu.
Little did young Kublai know it, but that
empire was about to fall into his family’s
hands.
On August 18, 1227, Genghis Khan died of injuries
sustained falling off a horse.
In the aftermath of the great Khan’s death,
control of the empire briefly passed to Kublai’s
father, Tolui.
It was the family’s first brush with immense
power.
It certainly wouldn’t be their last.
The Age of Expansion
In the wake of Genghis Khan’s death, a kuriltai,
or great gathering of Mongol leaders was called.
There, the decision was made that Tolui should
hand control of the empire over to Genghis’s
other son, Ögedei.
This was something of a weird choice.
Ögedei was a guy so dedicating to drunkenness
that, when other Mongol leaders ordered him
to cut down to just three cups of wine a day,
he started drinking from cups roughly the
size of bathtubs.
He also had no practical experience of conquering.
What Ögedei did have, though, was an ability
to delegate.
His view of the empire was:
“You can conquer an empire on horseback,
but you cannot govern it on horseback.”
So, while great generals like Subutai were
sent West to keep conquering, anyone with
a more civilized bent of mind stayed home
to keep things in order.
It was this philosophy that led to Kublai
getting his first practical experience of
ruling.
In 1236, Ögedei granted Kublai a fiefdom
of 10,000 homes in modern Hebei.
At first, the 21-year old Kublai was all like
“booooooooooorrrrrrrrring.”
He ignored his duties, sending agents to do
all the burdensome stuff like collecting taxes.
Unfortunately, these agents were exactly as
competent as you’d expect a bunch of Mongol
raiders to be, and the twin threats of taxation
and terror soon left Kublai’s province almost
empty.
It was only at the end of the decade that
Ögedei seems to have told Kublai, “dude,
use that province or lose it,” and Kublai
finally started acting like a ruler.
But while the role may have been forced on
him, there’s no doubt he excelled at it.
With Kublai now on the scene, all those incompetent
tax collectors were fired, and replaced by
experienced Chinese officials.
At the same time, Kublai began consulting
Chinese advisors more and more.
Although they were just a part of his local
court - a court that also included Christians
and Muslims - they soon edged the other voices
out.
It seems that Kublai just couldn’t get over
his childhood fascination with all things
Chinese.
For the other Mongols, this was shocking.
Who would voluntarily exchange manly Mongol
traditions like hunting and fighting for wussy
Chinese ones like tea and reading?
But Kublai wasn’t to be deterred.
He became interested in Buddhism, began to
appreciate Confucianism - including the revolutionary
idea that the well-being of an empire’s
subjects was just as important as that of
its rulers.
Still, these interests seemed laughably irrelevant
to other Mongols.
The empire was currently pushing into Europe,
the unconquered south of China forgotten about.
What need would the Mongols have for pretentious
Chinese guff now?
Yeah, about that.
On December 11, 1241, Ögedei died of a stroke.
At that precise moment, the Mongols were laying
waste to Eastern Europe.
Kyiv had been sacked, Krakow put to the sword,
and raiding parties were knocking at the gates
of Vienna.
Then word arrived of Ögedei’s death, and
the conquerors simply turned around and went
home.
At least, that’s the story.
Some historians think the retreat was sounded
for other reasons, and Ögedei’s death was
just a convenient excuse.
Whatever the truth, the upshot was that Europe
was forgotten about while the messy issue
of Ögedei’s successor was sorted.
After a few years of quarreling, it was eventually
decided that Kublai’s older brother, Möngke,
should be great Khan.
And Möngke was a guy as obsessed with China
as Kublai.
From now on, the Mongol focus wasn’t gonna
be on rampaging further and further into Europe…
But on conquering the last independent parts
of China.
In Xanadu…
No sooner had Möngke been declared great
Khan than he gave Kublai two very important
things.
One was Northern China.
Yep, the Mongol Empire in 1251 was so vast
that Möngke could basically gift half of
China to his brother and say “hope you like!”
The second was an order, one designed to test
Kublai’s mettle.
Möngke wanted Kublai to conquer the Dali
Kingdom.
At this point, Kublai had never run a military
campaign, and there was no guarantee he wouldn’t
turn out to be the Mongol equivalent of Mister
Bean.
It took Kublai a whole year to prepare to
fight the Dali.
A whole year in which he practiced tactics,
and read great Chinese thinkers on the arts
of war.
Finally, in 1253, Kublai saddled up, got his
army together, and rode into the Dali Kingdom.
The conquest took three years.
But it wasn’t three years marked by the
usual Mongol atrocities.
Kublai by now firmly believed what his Chinese
advisors had taught him about a ruler’s
codependence with the ruled.
Which meant not killing new subjects during
conquest, but treating them with mercy.
For the Mongols, this was seriously cuckoo
stuff; like if a modern general suggested
his army tried replacing its bullets with
Black Forest gateau.
But Kublai was serious.
Terror was to be toned down, and pillaging
was out.
And so a new era of Mongol warfare was born.
By 1256, the Dali Kingdom had fallen.
Buoyed by his brother’s success, Möngke
began planning an invasion of southern China,
where the Song Dynasty still held out.
But such an undertaking required time, time
in which Kublai wasn’t just gonna park his
thumb up his ass and wait for his brother
to say “go”.
So Kublai left Dali and returned north to
embark on his most-famous project of all.
Xanadu is legendary in the English-speaking
world.
Although this is mostly due to Coleridge’s
poem, it deserves the hype.
Kublai’s new capital was designed on Chinese
principles of feng shui, perfectly placed
in relation to mountains and rivers, between
the agricultural lowlands and Mongolian steppe.
Great walls and towers enclosed a city of
200,000 people, all laid out on a classic
Chinese square plan.
At its heart sat a palace almost beyond imagination,
a “stately pleasure dome” complete with
its own hunting grounds.
It was an expression of Kublai’s love for
Chinese style… but also of his power.
Power that was growing by the minute.
In 1258, Kublai invited leaders of both Buddhist
thought and Daoism to Xanadu for a grand religious
debate.
There, he listened to both sides, before eventually
declaring that Buddhism had won and making
it Northern China’s official religion.
It a decision that would play a huge part
in Buddhism’s spread across East Asia.
But as Kublai’s stature grew, Möngke began
to take notice.
The same year as the religious debate, he
sent agents to Xanadu, who began purging Kublai’s
Chinese advisors on trumped-up charges.
For a moment, it looked like there could be
civil war between the brothers.
But Möngke backed off at the last moment,
realizing he needed his brother for the coming
fight against the Song.
They patched things up and, in 1259, finally
invaded southern China.
Sadly, though, the civil war hadn’t been
stopped.
It would now just take place between different
siblings.
On August 11, Möngke died while besieging
a Song city.
Immediately, two candidates for his successor
presented themselves.
Up in Mongolia proper, Kublai’s younger
brother Arigböge was at the head of a conservative
faction, displeased with Möngke’s China
war.
Down in the south, there was Kublai, even
now fighting the war his brother had so long
dreamed of.
There was only one way a Khan could ever be
chosen between the two siblings.
They were going to have to fight.
The Wrath of the Khan
If anyone ever had any doubt about Kublai’s
ambitions, they were quickly dispelled after
Möngke’s death.
As soon as he could, Kublai made a peace treaty
with the Song.
Then he quick marched back up north to Xanadu
and, on May 5, 1260, called a kuriltai.
It ended with Kublai being elected great Khan
and a proclamation drawn up in classical Chinese.
But while Kublai’s meeting had named him
leader, this wasn’t the same as him actually
leading the Mongols.
Up in Karakorum, Arigböge responded to the
news by essentially going “oh, yeah?”
and holding his own kuriltai which named him
great Khan.
It was a stalemate.
Kublai now controlled the biggest, richest
part of the empire, while Arigböge ruled
the homeland.
It’s arguable that this stalemate was never
really resolved.
Although Kublai defeated Arigböge’s forces
in 1264, the north of the empire remained
out of his control.
The conservative faction replaced Arigböge
with a guy called Kaidu, and Kaidu basically
just did his own thing, like he was separate
from Kublai’s empire.
It’s around this point that we can stop
thinking of the Mongol Empire as a single
entity, and more like the collection of Khanates
it would eventually become.
Still, nominal control of the homeland was
good enough for Kublai.
Arigböge defeated, he went straight back
to war with the Song Dynasty.
It was a hell of a fight.
Although only in control of southern China,
the Song could still call up an army of one
million men.
They had gunpowder, catapults, siege engines.
A navy with the biggest ships in human history.
It was a fight Kublai had no guarantee he
could win.
So why did he bother?
The reason was simple.
Kublai didn’t just want to make the Song
submit.
He wanted to reunify China.
Prior to Kublai Khan, the last time China
had been unified had been under the Tang Dynasty,
who’d fallen 360 years before.
To give you some idea of how ridiculously
long ago that was, traveling back in time
360 years from today would land you in 1660.
In 1660, Oliver Cromwell had only just died.
New York was still New Amsterdam.
Louis XIV was on the French throne.
Kublai’s dream of reuniting China was like
you meeting someone today who dreams of returning
the Thirteen Colonies to England.
It was mad, laughable.
It was also something he totally succeeded
at.
By 1271, Kublai had established a new capital
at modern-day Beijing, and renamed his empire
in the Chinese style, declaring it the Yuan
Dynasty.
By the mid-1270s, Song generals were defecting,
swearing allegiance to the new Yuan emperor.
At last, on March 28, 1276, the boy emperor
of the Song was captured and taken as prisoner
to Beijing.
Although Song loyalists would fight on for
three more years, the writing was on the wall.
The final end came on March 19, 1279.
On that day, a titanic naval battle took place
near modern Macu.
When it was finally over, there was no-one
left to oppose Kublai Khan.
Aged 63, the great Khan had at last finished
his brother’s work.
China was now conquered, reunified, and at
the mercy of the Mongols.
Only, the other Mongols didn’t quite see
it that way.
In the course of the conquest, Kublai’s
Yuan Dynasty had begun to take on more and
more Chinese characteristics, until it seemed
completely alien.
No-one knew what was coming next, but they
may have agreed on one thing.
Whatever form Yuan rule took, it certainly
wasn’t going to be Mongol in nature.
A Traveller from an Antique Land
In 1275, three bedraggled men arrived at Kublai’s
Khan’s vast marble palace.
They came from the distant city of Venice,
over 7,500 km away.
The older two were merchants, while the younger
was a lad of barely twenty with a gift for
languages.
They’d come intending only to stay a short
while.
But when the Khan saw them, he was so impressed
with the youngest that he made them stay for
16 whole years.
The name of that young man?
As you’ve already guessed, it was Marco
Polo.
And it’s his account of Kublai’s court
that still forms the basis of how we see the
Yuan Dynasty.
By the time Polo presented himself to the
great Khan, the growing empire was already
in full swing.
Under the Yuan, China entered a period of
incredible prosperity, but one that wasn’t
quite the uncomplicated picture of perfection
that Polo painted.
On the good side, Kublai was a ruler who was
seriously into innovation.
Under his watch, everything from an empire-wide
postal service to the issuing of paper money
was established.
But Yuan China wasn’t just about physical
improvements.
Kublai was also a leader in innovative thinking.
Freedom of religion was embraced.
Any language from around the empire was permitted
at court, and Kublai even hired a team to
create an artificial language which would
bind his subjects together - although this
never caught on.
There were scientific advances, too.
Kublai had accurate maps made of China, established
institutes of medicine, and improved the calendar.
He also turned Chinese society on its head.
Under the Song, artisans and doctors had been
discriminated against as useless idiots who
spent time doing stuff with their hands rather
than refining their minds with Confucian poetry.
But Kublai flipped that.
He handed artisans enormous tax breaks, promoted
doctors and astronomers.
The result was an economic boom that dragged
reunified China into the new era.
But Kublai’s outward successes masked some
deeper failures.
One was a state policy of racial discrimination.
While Kublai played the part of the Chinese
emperor, wearing traditional robes and allowing
himself to be carried around by servants,
the reality was that his China was deeply
discriminatory towards Chinese.
The Yuan had four social classes.
At the top were Mongols, who held all the
key posts.
Second were useful foreigners, like Marco
Polo or the Khan’s Muslim treasurers.
Third were northern Chinese, who shouldered
a heavy tax burden.
And fourth were the southern Chinese, who
were considered lower than vermin.
The result was millions of Chinse crushed
by taxes, and treated like strangers in their
own land.
On a personal level, too, Kublai wasn’t
quite the serene emperor of popular imagination.
The Khan drank like a fish, ate like a pig,
and screwed like a rabbit.
The result was that he eventually transformed
into a fat, gout-ridden, horny blob prone
to outbursts of temper.
And yet, for all these faults, there’s no
doubting Kublai’s legacy.
In Chinese official historiography, the Yuan
era is regarded not as an Interregnum, but
as part of the imperial story - an honor only
afforded to one other foreign dynasty: the
Qing.
But while Kublai’s rule at home might be
complicated, there’s no such shades of gray
regarding his foreign policy.
That’s because his time as emperor was taken
up not with being a great administrator, a
powerful warrior, or even a champion drunk…
…but with an endless series of disastrous
wars.
The Other Great Khan
One of the most-interesting things about Kublai
is that there always seem to have been two
people in his head, fighting for control.
One was Kublai the Yuan Emperor, who wanted
nothing more than to follow his childhood
obsession with all things Chinese, and settle
down as a wise ruler.
The other was Kublai Khan, the Mongol warrior,
who felt his life should be taken up with
conquest.
Sadly for Kublai’s prosperity, in his later
years it was Kublai the warrior who won out.
We say “sadly” because, despite his early-life
victories against the Dali, the Song, and
Arigböge, late-life Kublai was a real putz
when it came to conquering.
There were his two invasions of Japan, in
1274 and 1281, which both times resulted in
typhoons wrecking his entire navy - an incident
which led to the Japanese concept of the “Divine
Wind” or kamikaze.
There were his two invasions of Vietnam, and
his two invasions of Burma, both of which
resulted in Pyrrhic victories thanks to their
sheer, insane cost.
Finally, there was Kublai’s 1292 invasion
of Java, which ended with the victorious Mongols
so riddled with disease that they were forced
to retreat after a single year.
It was a disappointing end to a dizzying career,
like riding a rollercoaster that reaches its
highest peak only to suddenly shut down and
leave you stuck and disappointed.
But it’s likely that, by the time of the
Java disaster, Kublai no longer cared.
In 1281 and 1285, the Yuan emperor had lost
first his favorite wife and then his eldest
son.
This one-two punch of tragedy seems to have
floored Kublai, who withdrew from the day-to-day
running of the empire, instead drowning his
sorrows in drinking and feasting.
By the time he finally allowed Marco Polo
to leave his court, the one-time warrior was
nothing but a fat, unhappy man, trapped in
a vast palace as luxurious as it was empty.
Kublai Khan finally died on February 18, 1294.
His body was buried in a secret place somewhere
in Mongolia.
As with his grandfather, Genghis Khan, his
remains have never been found.
In the years after Kublai’s death, two important
things happened that would ensure his place
in history.
The first was that Marco Polo’s book appeared,
forever fixing an image of the Khan as a wise
and benevolent ruler.
The second was the collapse of the Yuan Dynasty.
Although Kublai’s descendants ruled China
peacefully for 30 years, in 1324 a series
of uprisings marked the beginning of the Dynasty’s
decline.
Come 1368, the Yuan were so weak that the
Ming were able to conquer China and establish
their own dynasty.
In the aftermath, the Mongols retreated back
to the steppe, never again playing an important
part in history.
But the same can’t be said of Kublai Khan.
In 1644, the Ming in turn fell to Manchu invaders:
the Qing.
As the new masters of China, the Qing looked
back to the last foreign dynasty as their
inspiration; as the golden age they hoped
to emulate.
In the story of Kublai Khan, they found the
template for their own Dynasty - a Dynasty
that would last until 1911.
Today, Kublai’s name still survives - less
as that of an historic figure, and more as
a byword for something romantic, poetic and
mystical.
Yet even this is more than than that afforded
to any other Mongol leader apart from Genghis
Khan.
More even than perhaps any other Chinese emperor.
Kublai Khan the man may be long dead, but
the stories of his exploits, the influence
his life had on others, ensure that his name
will live on forever.